my President Trump is pushing for
sweeping tax cuts in major tax reform
why to unleash the American economy and
provide relief to the American people
why because millions of Americans
desperately need the help and the growth
of the economy now the president sat
down with a group of bipartisan
lawmakers at the White House earlier
today and here's what he said we're four
principles for tax reform make the tax
code simple and fair cut taxes
substantially it'll be the largest tax
decrease in the history of our country
for the middle class encourage companies
to hire and grow in America and by doing
that we're gonna have to reduce the
taxes for companies another bipartisan
project that is urgently needed is
infrastructure and infrastructure
investment it's time now to build new
roads new bridges airports tunnels
highways and railways all across our
great land we don't want to forget Daka
and it's already been a week and a half
and people don't talk about it as much
we want to see if we can do something
with regard to immigration with regard
to the 800,000 people that are now young
people than our children anymore they
were children now they're young people
but we want to see if we can do
something in a bipartisan fashion we
want to get our country working again
and competing again worldwide and
there'll be nothing that can stop us now
notice but for daca the president was
echoing everything he promised you in
the campaign now the president also
wrote on Twitter earlier today the
approval process for the biggest tax cut
and tax reform package in the history of
our country will soon begin move fast
Congress and he added with Emma and
Harvey devastation tax cuts and tax
reform is needed more than ever before
go Congress go now President Trump is
right the time for tax reform is right
now we did not do this since 1986 and
tonight the president dined with
Democratic leaders Chuck Schumer and
Nancy Pelosi here's what's happening
look the president is reaching across
the aisle to try and get things done
because let's face it Republican
leadership in Congress
they have failed miserably and at every
turn now Republican failure their broken
promises they have now left the
president with no other option if he's
going to keep his promises to the
American people they have proven
themselves to be incompetent ineffective
and the president frankly I don't blame
him he's done waiting and he's forging
ahead with or without Mitch McConnell
we'll have more on him in just a second
but first let's look at some of these
statistics on how massive and how
burdensome this tax system in this
country has now become now according to
Republican members on the House Ways and
Means Committee the current federal tax
code look at this over 70,000 pages who
could ever comprehend that now put that
in perspective for you back in 1913 when
the income tax was introduced there's
only four hundred pages long
now the tax foundation all also has an
estimate that Americans spent eight
point nine billion hours in tax
preparation last year and that
translates to over 400 billion dollars
in lost productivity now the president
understands this all has to change
because unlike the vast majority of
politicians in the swamp and the sewer
and the so-called policy wonks in DC
well the president he's actually run a
business and here's what the president
has been calling for paid close
attention he wants bold tax cuts and tax
reforms he wants an emphasis on
benefiting the middle class including
middle-class tax cuts he wants seven
brackets to go to three brackets to make
it easy and simple he wants that 15
percent corporate tax rate why because
that makes American businesses more
competitive on the global stage and of
course he's been talking about allowing
multinational corporations what to
repatriate trillions of dollars that
they have sitting overseas at a low rate
and that way they can invest in American
workers and build factories and
manufacturing centers right here in
Michigan in Wisconsin in Ohio and
Pennsylvania and of course he's also
pushing energy independence why because
there are literally millions of
high-paying career jobs available and
the Treasury secretary Steve minuchin
he's saying the administration wants to
make these tax cuts retroactive Wow
people start spending money texas
senator ted
we'll join us in just a minute he's also
offering up his own tax reform plan now
here's the senator explaining today what
you the American people need and why you
need tax reform
take a look our economy since World War
two has grown on average three point
three percent a year and yet for the
past eight years we've been mired in
stagnation from 2008 to 2012 the economy
grew on average 0.9 percent a year
Ronald Reagan was elected on a promise
of tax cuts of tax reforms we saw
historic tax reform in 81 at 86 and by
the fourth year of Reagan's presidency
1984 we went from stagnant economic
growth
less than 1% a year to 7.2 percent a
year
massive booming growth lifting millions
out of poverty increasing significantly
median income senator cruz was right in
the reagan years reagan went from 70 to
28 percent top marginal tax rates in
this country okay how did a result
government doubled the revenues that
they had in eight years 20 million new
jobs were created and by the way here
are the highlights of what senator Cruz
is proposing this makes perfect sense
and it's simple and it's easy and it's
basic and it's fundamental a low flat
tax rate tax returns that can be filed
on a postcard immediate expensing for
businesses a low corporate tax rate
there were patreon ending the death tax
getting rid of the alternative minimum
tax now President Trump and Senator
Cruz's philosophy on tax reform is
simple they want to get the government
off your back and let you keep more of
your hard-earned money in your wallet
spend it the way you want and as we've
been seeing President Trump is working
non-stop he wants to get his major
agenda items past with members of
Congress meeting with them day and night
and by taking his message on the road
and speaking directly to the American
people now it's time for Congress I
cannot believe they have no urgency get
your job done and I'm specifically
talking about you senator Mitch
McConnell and the never Trump is out
there late let's see John McCain Lindsey
Graham Jeff Flake Oh Ben Sasse we'll add
him to the list
you know what it's now or never and by
the way no more excuses as to why you
can't keep your promises all it's so
hard well for seven and a half years you
promise to repeal replace Obamacare and
you couldn't get it done no more blaming
the president like Mitch McConnell did
last month and he said the president had
excessive expectations and well he
doesn't understand the parliamentary
procedures and the difficulties of
legislation because he's never done this
before
take a look that's so pathetic that's
that's the swamp that's the sewer and
now according to roll call Senator
McConnell is now saying tax reform they
have to wait until next year this is
pathetic it's inexcusable it's
unacceptable why did we elect you now
it's time for an ultimatum
Senator McConnell other Republicans if
you don't get the urgency to work for
the American people and you don't pass
tax reform by the end of this year you
need to resign go home play golf and get
out of the way and let's get people in
those positions that can serve the
American people
I'm tired of the complacency and
business as usual you know what it's not
been working Congress is now failing the
American people 50 million Americans in
poverty 50 million on food stamps 90
plus million out of the labor force
lowest home ownership rate in 51 years
really this is why Congress you have an
approval rating that hovers around 15
wonderful percent that's why Mitch
McConnell has a dismal 18% approval
rating in his own home state of Kentucky
now instead of whining and complaining
and pointing figures about why you can't
pass legislation you people in
Washington in Congress time to roll up
your sleeves get in a room I'll send you
pizza and beer and turn off the air
conditioner like our framers and
founders and get to work and don't leave
the room until you build consensus to
help people you know it's not like these
issues or ideas are new just like with
Obama care what have you been doing
you've been promising and promising and
running and elect us and elect us the
American people
been doing this for years and you know
what you said you're gonna do this you
said you'll cut taxes you said you'll
pass reform you said you'll repeal and
replace where is your sense of urgency
every American I know has a sense of
urgency on their job where's your
accountability now the president can't
do everything on his own you need to
hold up your end of the bargain you need
to accomplish something for once